bootleg cat podcast man we got a special
guest in here Fontana is in the building
the IE is here what's the area Chris
King
tell y'all get up here it's probably
watch out man what's going on welcome
welcome what do you got going on I know
you you I just saw one of the freestyles
you did uh
there was like a green screen behind you
shout out corner store in La yeah yeah
shout out to them that [__] was super
fireman they just had the wrestle on
there today a word that's super dope
shout out to the Russell man shout out
to Desi and the rest of the thing for
sure you already know uh but in terms of
like music like before we have you uh
get your wrap on bro plug your [__] oh
yeah man uh Chris King snotty knows
records 1400 FEA
um yeah man you know what I do be
dropping mixtapes for a minute about to
drop this [__] called the green tape and
um are you like you're affiliated with
trippy red heavily yeah okay heavily but
I'm not I'm not um people getting
mistaken like we have more of like a
super like really together like that's
my brother right he's not a business
Thing Worth so it's really like we
really super nice guy too we're damn
near related I'm gonna just say that
that's right he's a super nice dude man
that's uh my little brother for showing
he looks out for me probably more than I
don't know anybody I'm gonna say that
shout out to Trippy red and uh shout out
to Chris King shout out to the IE in
here we've had a lot of IE rappers
lately yeah man we're gonna keep it
going shout out price man shout out to
price shots
ain't that [__] too come okay
right
let's go
yeah
the [__] was I thinking
the green tape [__]
snotty's the name it's not he's the Gang
14.
FBA yeah
you did
man magic music out now go get my
brother out [__] number one
gang [__]
listen I got a beautiful soul but I felt
alone and abandoned [__] one dick and
Chanel we switching like TV channels I
Come From the Bottom of the dirt we easy
with disadvantages pitch Me I'm Dreaming
woke up with money how did this happen
scheming their name is a product bucket
with a hat to match it balling all
season this season That season therefore
the after it's all for a reason put dog
in this need to help all collapse you
walking with demons just watch where
your feet as the floor is lava I seen a
[__] sell a whole soul for some
Reposado seen a [__] get a bloody nose
with a bag of powder all the mark with
the time froze with the glass around it
back against the wall will you set it
off if your ass around it running
through the jungle head hunting get a
trophy mounted and I keep a little
scrappy head busted it could go down
south ride my head rushing cause I'm
running booming out the mouth [__] your
dead homies in the dirt we could dig
them out [__] got that white girl kick
like Ronda Rousey nowadays a colorful
weed bag don't mean the weed is loud out
of town as y'all need to learn your Los
Angeles boundaries you might get smoked
by your vato look like J Balvin State
really silly the motherland of them gang
files stash by silly the state trooper
just can't find it [__] all the [__] I
said push it to the red I hope this
bullet just grew legs and then it run
off in your head [__] 175 online for
ate a high tech exotic cookies and the
hybrids open the thighs I dive in metal
rot sheep lighting I pop a Perkins time
stick do you got a [__] for my friend I
made a squirt in my bench whoa hold on I
got rich on accident [__] wasn't forced
wait no I got rich on accident [__]
wasn't forced yeah I said I got rich on
accident [__] was a force yeah I got
rich an accident [__] wasn't forced
personally
[Music]
yeah
I came here my [__] came to back Yola
we was moving cloaks and sniffers put
the coke inside the cola came a private
flight to be moving to California you
know why let it blow out these [__]
know why don't know the way I let off a
flow dot super shot these [__] get hit
with too many of them
nah ain't too many of them pull up in
Range Rovers there's too many of them
black trucks them black sleeves we got
too many of them caught a ticket with
future and trip he knew me from Street
soldiers reigning Drake new me cause
twist brought me I can't stay sober Dirk
told me [__] it's up [__] remain going
rapper Kendrick years ago and [__] I'm
still exploding [__] you [__] didn't
even think this [__] is real decoded
messages I gotta get the [__] they
didn't really know it I'm really blowing
anytime I got that weed on me blowing
mucus cause I got my own runts these
[__] always from but I just do my own
that's Evil Knievel did 5 million in
about 16 months and that was easy
because I'm independent like it's Webbie
[__] never even seen it but these
[__] never fail me uh check the tech
ship you can
yeah dude let's check the text [__] you
can
I let it fly let it fly like a [__] in
Neverland never Dan I never fold and
never been yo and anytime the weather is
I make it rain
Chris King these [__] looking like a
stank and I never change I remain the
same green coming soon man that was
crazy I'll just saying crazy brother
that was crazy I didn't say anything
well that's really off the top you
already know go follow him man what's
your IG one more time hey man who is
Chris King man snotty knows Mafia snotty
knows records 1400 fva 800 you know it's
going on to the game and uh yeah man you
know it's popping man we doing this all
year 2023 boo that cat [__] up and
brought me up here yeah you're gonna see
a lot more green tape coming soon
[__] hey what up y'all appreciate you
guys watching this week's freestyle
we're dropping another one next week and
sometimes we drop more than one in a
week but they're always brought to you
by LRG baby that's right loving me some
LRG always and right now if you go to
the website
l-r-g.com and you use the promo code
bootleg you're gonna get 30 off 30 off
that's almost half
at checkout that's right all right shout
out to LRG one more time L Dash R Dash
g.com and when you check out use that
promo code bootleg and save 30 off the
freestyles we'll be back next week
always brought to you by LRG baby